[Music]
[Applause]
ian rappaport had the big story the
national insider for the nfl network and
uh you can follow him on twitter at rap
sheet the contract with kyla murray ian
kind enough to join us here uh who would
benefit from wanting the uh mandatory
film study to be made public
uh who would benefit i'm not sure
anybody would benefit from that but i
don't so it's interesting when a story
becomes public like this and everyone
sort of questions like why and you know
what was the motivation and and all that
which is all fine like i know that's all
part of it um
but the way this worked so i requested
the contract when when contracts are
officially signed then they're put in a
i guess database i was thinking about it
like it was a file cabinet if i assume
it's something electronic and
agents can get copies of it through the
nfl pa
and contract guys the nfl can get copies
through the nfl so if you have some you
know the right sources and honestly it
doesn't take very much you request a
contract once it's signed to be like i
want to take a look at it
and so that's what i did and i was
actually looking for the baseball clause
because there's a clause in calamari's
contract that says his guarantee gets
voided if he plays organized baseball
for any team at any time during his
contract that's what i was looking for
so
you know once that
once i took a look at it and i realized
there was this independent study clause
i had to call like sort of an expert of
reading contracts to be like
am i
am i doing this properly
um
can you i don't know if you just lost me
hold on oh my god
am i doing this properly and am i
understanding this properly um and i was
and so i called the agent that here's
what i got here's an omni report and
then you know then i reported it
have you heard of a contract anything
similar to this before
no
to my knowledge i do not know of
anything that has been
uh i don't know about anything similar
in any nfl contract honestly
cliff kingsbury said he had no issues
with kylo murray
his study habits
you believe him
uh
i believe that this
uh
contract clause was something that
michael bidwell the owner wanted and my
understanding of the
the reason was
um
they're going to make a commitment to a
quarterback like this they're going to
make you know pay him 230.5 million
dollars make him the face of the
franchise and all that they wanted
something coming back they wanted him
making a written commitment to them that
he's going to do all the necessary
things so it wasn't just this cause it
was also the nine or so million dollars
in workout bonuses tied to him being in
town
um it was
um you know some community commitments
where he's gonna come in and kind of be
the face of their franchise like he
should be being paid that money
um so there was all sorts of things that
michael bidwell wanted if he was going
to do what was a historic contract for
the arizona cardinals
do you think there's fallout further
fallout from this
do you mean are we gonna hear this ever
again in the hit and the history of
calamari's career i think we might hear
it a time or two yeah god forbid
something happens where he does not look
good in the game like is someone gonna
ask have you been studying yeah i think
they probably will but
if he's doing what he needs to do if
he's doing what he has to do and
studying like i mean i'm sure he does
more than four hours by himself every
week um
you know hopefully he's doing what's
necessary it's not an issue but are
people going to ask absolutely
uh help me understand that
deshaun watson situation that i think
it's four weeks ago that they sort of
wrapped up everything with this
independent arbitrator the judge
what is holding up any decision here for
her
um sorry i'm texting as i'm talking to
you um
basically i you know i don't know if
it's holding up a decision but the more
time she has the more time
that there's a possibility the nfl and
the nfl pa can
get together and maybe come up with a
settlement i don't sense anything as
imminent nor does either party want to
do right now but
you know take some time and that
would be continue to be on the table you
know we all have a time frame of
um wanting to make sure that
it was done before training camp she did
not yeah um she did not so
you know we always say oh expected
before training that's if the nfl and
the nflpa were in charge they are not
sue robinson is it is on her timetable
there's no actual the only thing that
matters to her is coming out with the
right and fair and just proper ruling
whether or not deshaun watson plays a
couple preseason practices training camp
practices before isn't actually material
to the situation
but do you think that the nflpa and the
nfl could negotiate
a number
and then say and then talk to her
yes
theoretically i don't get the sense that
they are going to but theoretically yes
they absolutely could and that that
would be except it was accepted by all
parties i think there could be a
settlement yes all right i know you're
busy i appreciate you joining us on
short notes all right thank you that's
ian rappaport national insider for nfl
network